welcome back y'all we're here with
Chrissy tan and Dav
J together we've got a new show called
Christy and Dave dying out you can see
it Wednesdays on free form and streaming
the next day on Hulu the show covers a
bunch of different categories of food so
it's time to test how well Christy and I
I will not but I know some of those
different categories not good at games
this you know food anyway this is quick
quick
categories quick quick
categories okay there we go oh my gosh
from that vocal I got hints of remember
Hercules the singers on The Hercules
soundtrack that's I love it gave me
those vibes you should check it out
anyway thank you for hosting um I know
you're so excited about it I was born
for this
moment all right tell us here we go all
right folks in this game I will give a
category of something that has to do
with food might be brands of food might
be types of restaurants Kelly and
Chrissy will take turns naming things
within that specific category when
someone gets one wrong repeats an answer
or takes longer than 3 seconds to answer
you'll hear this
sound I'm going to throw
up I didn't even understand the rules so
I like if you get the buzzer that means
the other person gets the point okay I
also don't understand what's going on
should go great Kelly is playing to win
a prize for the left of the
audience
Chrissy is playing for the right side
over by the
B are you guys ready yes all right
category one okay Chrissy starts kitchen
appliances oh um food processor
blender why you looking at
me ice cream
maker like an ice
maker cheated kind of um a ninja is that
a kind of a blender but yeah
um so um so um an oven oh oh I
gotone all right I know for a fact you
let me have that because you I did not I
did not you know you should know me
better than I don't let anyone win I
don't even like my seven I don't all
right category two Kelly ready yeah soft
drink Brands oh Dr Pepper that's my
favorite oh Coke um Pepsi Mountain Dew
Sprite squirt
Fanta lecoy
oh Dr Thunder it's the off Thunder the
off BR Dr
[Music]
Pepper that's what my mom would buy like
store yeah
next category Chrissy shapes of pasta
shapes of pasta
fili
what
P
bucatini
spaghetti
lasagna angel hair good one um kabat
tapi she heard me C cell you said it
wrong
C
[Applause]
C you know had a CP that's the thing I
didn't know you could have gotten away
with
it I just remembered fousy Jerry from
Seinfeld and that's like my only
reference never heard life before foods
that start with the letter j jack fruit
that's really good and very Asian okay
um
Jam
Jello I still can't think of one I don't
know either Jelly Bean jelly bean I I
was sticking I think once you get it
yeah I don't
know last category last category you're
killing it by the way dude I'm going to
honestly throw fast food restaurant yeah
baby Burger King Taco Bell McDonald's
flat Burger Del Taco Dairy
Queen um AMW
KFC popy oh good um Chicken Express
Shake Shack oh schlis Chick-fil-A is
Shake Shack a fast food yes yes yes oh
okay um and then um oh sorry T Taco
Bueno uh um El poo Loco oh kind of
Jeopardy okay um oh Wendy's oh that is a
good one oh like oh no no no no no what
what about it could to be like
a
finally that's when that's when being a
closet fat kid works out that's all I'm
saying yeah you ain't going to beat me
you're too skinny to beat give me a fast
food everyone everyone wins on the Kelly
Clarkson show Millions rely on Yelp to
connect with trusted local businesses
from restaurants to Home Services this
week Yelp announced their top 100 places
to eat in the country so you can dine at
your favorite restaurant Yelp is giving
everyone here $200 Visa gift
[Applause]
card watch CHR and out ring from free
and streaming
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home